my middle name is gilchrist and uh it's
very english of you right it was my
grandfather's middle name
but at some point i want to say i was
like well how old would i have been like
seven or eight
maybe a tad younger because it was
connecticut and and cindy started
calling me gilly
and like says hey gilly and i don't even
know why but i was so upset about that
and because i was upset
cindy wood hammered a little harder yeah
not the same i had so few levers that
you know when i found one not that cindy
was particularly mean but that that's
probably the the meanest you ever were
i'll take that yeah that's pretty good
yeah that's great gilly gilly gilly
and then later when you were about
12 and i was 15
it became apparent that at some point in
the not very distant future you were
going to physically get bigger than me
and my days of being able to sit on you
and beat you up if needed
were numbered so i was going to need the
psychological advantage
since the physical edge was rapidly
evaporating and i think that's probably
about the time i started calling you
squirt which you didn't mind and it
became your tag you spray painted it on
the side of the building at the
university of miami and put it on your
skateboards and you know
and i still call you squirt and to my
kids you know sometimes your uncle
squirt but um the uh
yeah that was that would that replaced
gilly
they got to see their uncle squirt last
night
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]